I am pleased to welcome to the platform
mr. James D Wolfensohn president of the
World Bank Group and the Honorable
Michael a Sullivan mayor of the city of
Cambridge mr. Wolfensohn will now give
his address
chairman Dolloff president vest members
of the corporation the faculty the
administration graduands your families
and friends
let me first say how deeply honored I am
to be here in what is essentially a
family celebration a celebration for
each of you on your achievements a
celebration at a very important moment
in your lives a moment when you are
reflecting a moment when you're looking
forward I feel deeply honored to be here
particularly as when I came this morning
I recalled with my own personal pleasure
my first visit from Australia in the
mid-50s
when I came past this wonderful building
looking to buy a copy of Paul
Samuelson's book on economics to try and
help me get through a course a little
bit down the road and this was an
occasion for me when I for the first
time put reality to my expectations and
hopes derived in Australia about
academic excellence about opportunity
about a chance to come and work within a
great country and in a great community
and to do so
with the possibility of developing my
own career this is indeed a great
institution an institution that has
enormous achievements in sciences in
social sciences and achievements which
have been marked by many previous
commencement speakers and by the world
at large but it's also an institution
which is engaged very much not just on
its past achievements but on its future
and we at our institution feel very
privileged to have relationships with
you and in particular on what I think
may well be the most significant advance
that this institution will ever have the
advance in relation to the opening of
your courses in the MIT open course
program in which we're engaged not just
with our African virtual University but
hopefully as the years progress in
making possible of the underlying
knowledge experience and education
forces that there are in this university
let me say that from my point of view
working in the bank dealing with the
issues of development that this
contribution may well be the greatest
thing that you've ever done and I
congratulate you and applaud you for the
opening of this prospect not only to
this country there but to the world I
have come here this morning as you might
gather a little bit nervous nervous
because of the reaction to the World
Bank nervous because I see being held up
grade cards with F on it I'm
particularly nervous about that I might
tell you because personally I got too
many of them when I went through
University and I thought that at this
stage my record would be forgotten and
to be reminded of it as I come here
today as a cruel blow so I would ask you
just as a better personal dignity if you
turn it the other
way it'll allow me at least to recognize
that in the last 40 years I've come some
distance I've come some distance not in
terms of academics but in terms of being
able to take some of the values some of
the experience that I learned in this
city and have had the opportunity to
apply it to a world that has been
ever-changing and different and it's to
that that I'd like to address just a few
remarks to you this morning when I came
to the United States over 40 years ago I
conceived of the world as a bipolar
place as a place in which there were the
rich and the poor a place in which there
was the developing world and the
developed world the north and the south
a world that was divided I conceived my
own career there's something that I
reviewed in essentially personal terms I
wanted to get a graduate degree I wanted
to deal with the issues of my own
personal poverty
I wanted to deal with the questions of
building a career and I also thought
because I came from a distant country
and I knew just a little about
development that it was the right thing
the moral and ethical thing to take an
interest in those less fortunate in the
developing world I felt comfortable on
my graduation day as I'm sure you do
today in my achievements I felt
comfortable that I was behind a wall
that I had made it and that I was now
going to advance with all the sense of
confidence that you get from the sort of
achievements that you have remarkably
made this day and I thought of this
other part of the world as being a world
to which I would give part of my life
and then I'd come back and
develop my life behind my wall I've
learned in the last seven years that the
world is not bipolar and simple but the
sort of thing that many of your students
this morning were talking to me about
and caused some reaction very often to
my own institution the notion of
globalization the notion of the
shrinking of the world has occurred most
significantly in this 40 years since my
graduation and today the world is a
different place for any that thought
that you could live behind the wall
September the 11th was a moment when
reappraisal had to take place this was a
moment when our country and indeed the
world were shocked and shaken to
recognize that events in Afghanistan
events in distant parts of the world in
events in Islam events in those areas
where people were under pressure and
disadvantaged were not issues that could
be conveniently kept outside a wall but
in fact were issues that impacted on us
that are part of the developed world
that the notion of two worlds is no
longer real there whether it be an
environment or in health or in crimes or
in migration or in drugs or in
communications or in terror issues in
one part of the world become issues in
another part of the world and for my own
organization which focuses so much on
the question of poverty for our
organization the question is what is it
that is the question of equity and
social justice in that other part of the
world and how does it affect us in the
privileged world well if everyone had
doubts
September the 11th I believe made us
recognize the reality that was there on
September the 10th which is the poverty
somewhere is poverty everywhere that
global issues are local issues that
issues of development are issues not
just in developing countries but issues
for us the numbers are compelling we
have a planet of six billion people five
billion of the people live in developing
countries three billion of the people
live under $2 a day and inequity is very
clear I have just come back from a trip
to East Timor Mongolia China the Middle
East through Central Asia each of these
countries is different but each reflects
a sense of inequity uncertainty although
a burgeoning area of hope for many
people but for all too many the question
of inequity finds its finds its evidence
and finds its manifestation in hostility
in reaction in a sense of abandonment
and that is an issue not just for those
countries it's an issue for us and as we
look forward to the lifespan that you
will have of the next 2530 years at
least our world becomes a world of eight
billion people seven billion people will
be in the developing and transition
economies twenty-five to thirty years
from now this is not a static situation
this is a situation where the five
billion has twenty percent of the global
assets and earnings and it's not a
situation that can continue it's a
situation which is essentially unstable
and it's not a distant issue and so my
message to you today is really a single
and simple message it's a message to say
to you that whatever you judge of
institutions like the bank or
contributions of people of my generation
your challenge is the challenge of
planetary equity your challenge is the
challenge of taking the experience that
you have had of the education that
you've had of the careers that you're
seeking to build and view them not
through the lens of a world that exists
behind a non-existent wall but to look
at your future as a world in which your
aspirations your dreams are
interdependent with those less fortunate
wherever they are it is not an issue you
can avoid it's an issue that you not
only Congrats but to which you have been
trained to advance let me give you just
one minor example drawn from a different
institution and try and put in
perspective what you've learned I was in
Georgia with a graduate recent graduate
in the field of development and
agricultural technology we visited a
farmer in a field and this rather
confident young man getting out of the
car went to the farmer and in pretty
good Georgia and said to him if I can
tell you how many sheep are in your
field will you give me one and the
farmer an equally good Georgian
responded yes I'll be glad to and my
young graduate friend looked around and
with a quick review said there are 873
sheep in your field and they're healthy
and the farmer said that's the most
amazing thing I have ever seen you're
correct
take one they bent down picked up an
animal started walking to the car when
the farmer said to him sir if I could
tell you which University you went to
would you give it back and my colleague
said yes he said well you went to
Harvard and he said you're right
how did you know he said well you picked
up my dog and my concern my concern
ladies and gentlemen is that you don't
pick up the dog that you use your
education with humility with openness
with concern because the issue of
poverty the issue of development the
issue of equity is your issue you cannot
avoid it it is the issue of peace and
you all of you here have been trained to
make our world a better place I have
great confidence that you will do that
and I hope that as you go forward you
will give thought not to the World Bank
but to the issue of equity social
justice poverty and peace thank you so
much
you